let's say that I have five lemons so
that's one two three four five lemons
and I were to ask you what do I have to
multiply times five to get one or in
this case what I have to multiply times
five lemons to get one lemon and so
another question you might ask because
really multiplication and division are
two sides of the same coin is what would
I have to divide five by to get to one
lemon or yellow circle or whatever I've
drawn right over here well if you have
five things and if you divide by five
you're going to have five groups of one
so if you divide by five you're going to
have one two three four five groups so
you could say five divided by five is
equal to one
you don't take five things divide it
into five groups each group is going to
have one in them or you could say five
times one-fifth is equal to one and I
used the dot for multiplication I could
also say five times one-fifth is equal
to one these are all really saying the
same thing maybe what's kind of
interesting here although it's not some
huge some huge learning it's it's really
just another way of writing what you've
already probably known is this idea that
if I have a number and I multiply times
its multiplicative inverse and most of
the time when people talk about inverses
in mathematics they're talking about the
multiplicative inverse then I'm going to
get one so five times one-fifth is equal
to one but that's the same that's just
because five times one-fifth is the same
thing as 5 divided by 5 if you would
actually multiply this out if you
actually take five times one-fifth this
is equal to 5 over 1 times 1 over 5 you
multiply the numerators 5 times 1 is 5
multiply the denominators 5 1 times 5 is
5 so you have five fifths and five
fifths is the exact same thing as one so
if someone were to ask you a question
they said hey I have the number 217 and
I want to multiply it by something and I
want to get one after multiplying it by
that something well you say well look if
I took 217 and I divide it by 217 that
would get me
one and dividing by 217 is the exact
same thing as multiplying by 1 over 217
multiplying by its multiplicative
inverse which is once again a word that
is fancier than the actual concept
you're just multiplying by the inverse
of this number another way to think
about it is if I have five things and if
I were to take one fifth of those five
things how many things do I have well if
I take one fifth of five things I have
exactly one thing right over here but
the general idea is super duper duper
simple if I have some crazy number eight
thousand three hundred and forty five
that's actually not so crazy let's me
turn into something in the millions and
271 so eight eight million three hundred
forty-five thousand two hundred
seventy-one and I say what do I have to
multiply that and I'll use this
multiplication symbol right now what do
I have to multiply that by in order to
get one well I just have to multiply by
the inverse of this the multiplicative
inverse of this so one over eight
million three hundred and forty five
thousand two hundred and seventy-one